hello everyone and welcome to a video uh
where I will be discussing certain
events basically the events that have
shaken up the chess world as we know it
it is the of course the Hans Magnus
drama that everyone's been talking about
it's been everywhere not just in chess
media even Elon Musk commented on it um
on Twitter in his in his own special way
uh so pretty much everyone knows about
this there's no question about that the
reason why I haven't discussed it um at
all because there was nothing to discuss
the only thing we had was a wind Magnus
left the tournament in St Louis uh he uh
just posted one tweet I'm sure you guys
have seen it but in case you are just
you know learning about this this is uh
magnus's tweet let me just bring that up
so what Magna says is I have withdrawn
from the tournament I've always enjoyed
playing in the St Louis chess car club
and hoped to be back in the future and
he posted a clip of Jose Mourinho saying
that if I speak I'm in big trouble I do
not follow football I did not know what
this mean means so I had to brush up on
my football knowledge but now that I
know uh you know what's it about it does
have certain implications on the Chess
World as well now uh after that uh event
Magnus did not speak about this at all
to anyone uh that we know of of course
and uh here he faced uh Hans again he
faced him in round six of the Julius
bear generation cup and Magnus just
resigned to the game without even
playing he did play one move he played
Knight to F6 but we're gonna discuss
that a little bit later so now what we
know uh for a fact that after uh
determined that Magnus won convincingly
the Holy Spirit generation cup
preliminaries uh Kaya one of the one of
the hosts of the of the show of the of
the Champions Chester asked Magnus some
very very difficult questions that
people
will usually don't ask you know at such
Point Blank so you know kudos for that
but when asked what does Magnus think
about all of this he said that he will
not comment maybe that he will leave
some comments after the tournament so he
he hopes uh to give an official
statement regarding the events that have
occurred but he did say uh at one point
and I'm quoting Magnus and this he says
I'm very impressed by Hans niemann's
play and I think him and his mentor Max
loogie must be doing a great job now of
course if you are new to chess and you
don't know much about what's been
happening outside of the main events uh
this doesn't mean all that much to you
however Hans has been studying under Max
loogie or rather he was a member of his
Academy he does run the chess Max
Academy and even Max loogie was well uh
obviously not maybe caught red-handed
but he was disqualified from a chess.com
title Tuesday with a perfect score of 8
out of eight before even being allowed
to play in round nine and I believe he
hasn't uh logged into chess.com ever
since there are I've read up somewhere
that he did log in once but maybe in
2020. but regardless of that he did win
two title Tuesdays before being um
disqualified in this event also with a
perfect score of a eight out of eight
and then I believe losing the final game
uh but okay uh not not so relevant uh so
that's why Magnus uh mentions it and he
says that they are doing quite a good
job and also I found a nice
um uh bit of interview with Max loogie
regarding chess cheating which I think
is um very relevant to this he says that
this is the real danger because if a
2600 player has this thing or rather a
cheating device he knows exactly how to
behave he knows exactly when to think
and he doesn't use it more than four
times during a game that's plenty to
destroy anyone at the critical Junction
you switch it on and find out which way
do I go this little Nuance I didn't see
okay fine goodbye that's it at that
point you may think for a long time
although you know the move but this uh
but this guy doesn't know he's just
mechanically playing uh the first move
of the computer so
um uh obviously he did uh quite a lot of
research on the topic or or maybe he
just claims that he did but uh you know
whole thing um uh you know it's not
presented in the in the greatest light
as as you can see and uh I mean it's
it's hard to say this was a classical
game so
uh you know like Magnus said everyone as
I've quoted him on the on top of the
board people certainly have drawn their
own conclusions which basically means
that uh since Magnus has not spoken
about this and people have just been you
know going from this Theory to that
theory to all sorts of wild theories
like the one that Elon Musk posted on
Twitter you know the the one with the
beads
um uh but obviously Magnus feels that
people have drawn the right conclusion
but however this this means nothing
without without any proof and uh so far
it would seem that Hans has won the the
the well the opening the middle game but
uh the end game is still to follow and
everyone of course is very very much
interested what Magnus has installed for
the end game of this of this uh
incredible Clash that has you know
shaken the core of the Chess World and
uh yeah that's uh that's pretty much it
not not more can be said about this as
no more info information was revealed uh
like I said Magna said that he hopes to
say a little bit more after the
tournaments and on a general basis he
thinks that cheaters in the future
should not be taken lightly either
online or over the board now that's
pretty much it that's what he said I
will put the entire interview with Kaya
in the description below will be the
first thing you will see it's some eight
minutes so if you have eight minutes of
time do check it out as there you will
you know hear Magnus say that
but what I found interesting was the nut
that Magnus resigned in the game against
the Hans uh during this tournament I
believe it was round six everyone was
very much looking forward to it but how
he resigned it Hans played the D4 Knight
sorry uh Hans played D4 Magnus played
Knight to F6 so he did not just resign
he played the move Knight F6 and then
hunt played Hans played C4 and then
Magnus resigned the game so why why play
Knight F6 why play a move without even
why don't you just resign so I guess it
could be meaningless it could be you
know just Magnus being weird but it
could also be a message could also be I
mean what is nice to F6 what is sf6 is
it some sort of a hidden message is
Magnus hinting at something uh I'm not
much of a detective myself but if you
guys have any any ideas you know do
share in the comments uh you know could
be could be a very very important
message could be some sort of a secret
code I don't know I mean why play a move
uh if you if your plan is to just resign
uh so yeah that's basically it nothing
more that we know of we'll have to wait
until the end of the of the main event
of the whole Year's third generation cup
and then Magnus will Magnus will most
likely speak up or maybe he will not but
what's interesting is that uh hunts and
Magnus are on the different sides of the
bracket so the only way for Magnus
enhance the meat in the finals is the
meet in the final so uh that's the only
way it will happen and what's
interesting is that uh will Magnus play
hunts in the finals or will he just uh
you know go to the finals and just
resign uh without playing a move or
playing a silly move like Knight to F6
so we'll have to wait and see the next
few days will again be uh filled with
speculation and uh well the accusations
and whatnot but I suggest we just enjoy
the games and you know what will happen
will happen I'm sure Magnus has some
sort of an endgame installed uh where he
will say more but until then I I really
suggest we just enjoy the games like for
example the one Hans played against
Levon it was a a brilliant Masterpiece I
mean uh definitely a game to show
everyone and they will say like what
what a game
uh so yeah uh that's uh the the game and
a little bit of info info regarding this
whole incident I haven't spoken about it
uh ever since it happened since there
was nothing to talk about you could only
make certain assumptions but now that
Magnus himself has given an interview I
decided to also also cover it uh so yeah
there you have it hope you guys were
well informed on this if you have
anything more to add like I said feel
free to uh you know add in the comment
section and also uh I mean many people
have many different different theories
maybe we can crack this Knight F6 code I
mean it's truly you know it it really
boggles the mind uh so yeah once again I
hope you hope you enjoyed it I would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
GoGo and I would like to thank
interior Stuart Matthew Derek King and
Brian Paquin for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful full event until it finishes
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day